when you get that like like tell me the
process do they like let you come and
like you you're playing with my people
ain't no I'm saying but like like let's
say it's your people right are you able
to kind of like go through a few joints
on the drive and be like I like this one
or like this one or they send it to you
like hey this one you can have this one
does that make sense they know I ain't
you know what I'm saying
she just
she's musically inclined right A lot of
people hit up for Stuff Drake you know
what I'm saying was it on on the
original beat that it was cut on or did
you take the vocal to put on a new beat
she got to be together with her people
and then you know I'm saying asked me
what I changed if I was like I just
wanted to let her do her thing so
I'm saying static and
re-emerge he never left but just kind of
get more introduced to
what I'm saying it is kind of crazy
because like if we think about like
Louisville and Kentucky overall like you
guys want to like a run right now you
know
I mean
Bryson yourself Jack Harlow
I feel like you guys didn't really have
too much of like a real national
identity but I feel like you in
particular have really like represented
like a side of Louisville that like we
never really got to see through a guy
like Bryson because he's obviously a r b
singer so you know for you like how
important is that for you to still kind
of like
make sure your
kind of carrying the state make sure
you're representing the state nationally
make sure you represent the city you
know what I'm saying I don't feel no
pressure this is
me I got
I know a lot of people you like to break
it up with Bryson dragons but at this
point I feel like we gotta stop breaking
it up because if we're going off sales
and accolades and stuff like
I'm like the guy yeah you know what I'm
saying and um got no gimmicks or no
funny [__] with me I just dropped the
music yeah my life and I got
stats to prove and I know [__] are in
the barbershop about who's bad like I
got gold Plex Platinum Plex that's a
lead artist you know what I'm saying
that's a big deal we got a gold album
the entire album it's a big deal man so
I ain't
I don't know I don't feel like it's it
they shouldn't jumble it up and say this
type of music this type like artist I
feel like I'm the
leading the Forefront of you know I'm
saying rap in general not just
Louisville I was gonna say what market
for you started to pick up on estg first
outside of Louisville like what was like
that City you were like oh this is
spreading this is moving somewhere like
I could actually go get a bag in this
place like was there a city that you
remember that like really kind of like
hey this is all at the same time kind of
like it just kind of all kind of
happened like wildfire quick I just was
moving around anyway so
people knew me like the streets knew me
anyway yeah they come with the music and
we pop up 80 [__] 80 chains 80 watches
it don't matter what if you get no
burning humming you know what I'm saying
yeah they're gonna they won't see what
you talking about yo
um I've seen this picture of you at the
NFL combine yeah which what you ain't
seen no picture no NFL I saw you in like
the NFL combine looking like workout
yeah like a workout was that just a
workout you were doing for a team I
don't know how you see the picture you
ain't read the article that came with it
I just saw a YouTube video where they
were talking about uh you and like I was
just watching some of your high school
highlights in your college [__] like I
saw like what YouTube video are you
saying dude I don't know man it was like
a it was like a YouTube video a show
like you announcing that you're going to
Indiana State and of course a YouTube
video call I don't know I just literally
typed in estg football highlights
and I was like damn this dude was a
beast
you play linebacker right
what do I got to do with
music [__] right man no I'm just curious
because I'm a big football fan so like
I'm just like
I just I'm a huge football fan I find it
fascinating that like you really like
have like a real high level like
football run you know what I'm saying
before the rap [__] like took off so
yeah I just think it's fast but
obviously a part of your story so
I know it doesn't have anything to do
with what's going on right now but
that's fair
um I was gonna ask you like when it
comes to I remember when you signed with
Gotti I remember the the viral moment
where there was just all this cash and
at that time I feel like there was like
a bidding war going on for estg at that
moment
um one what made you rock with Gotti and
what is something over the last two or
three years that you have learned I mean
you know
well
for the very first time in bootlegate
podcast history
we had someone walk off of the set
interesting
oh well well there's the STG interview
that he was two hours late for
oh